hi guys it's a media Clark you might
know me as Khaleesi or mother of dragons
or breaker chains or any of the above I
want to take you to Westeros because I
hate to break it to you but it's the
last season of Game of Thrones so I've
teamed up with omae's to give one lucky
winner and a friend a pal a wife a lover
a dog a mother a brother a dad whoever
you want to come and visit the set and
have lunch but right now I want to give
you the viewer an exclusive
behind-the-scenes they'll sneak peek
they'll taste her a little amuse-bouche
if you will closed set not for me
usually looked it's just um it's okay
we'll go we'll go around the back okay
so let me never with you guys their
producers don't really want me doing
this in fact they don't really know I'm
doing this they also don't know I swipe
the key so yeah come on let's go okay so
listen I know everything's under wraps
but they've forgotten they're dealing
with the mother of dragons so stay right
there I'll be right back don't worry
about a thing I got this we're getting
you onto a set super Tom Segar close
sets mm-hmm
but we can't let you in all right fine
sorry okay so they practically begged me
to take you onto this set right but it's
not a good set but there's a really
top-secret set then I'm gonna take you
guys on to it's like like the : guys
just a few feet away is the most iconic
set in all of gamers rights the Iron
Throne
oh yeah come with me
this is the iron throne you can be
sitting in it there's dragons can you
see him you can add the dragons right
and you can add the throne and we're
gonna just add that in so I'm just not
sitting on it and this is just the green
room oh my trailer my rules
I'm gonna show you something real
special the script of the final season
of Game of Thrones Oh
so let's have a read shall we she turned
to her dragons
and we just realized something
you want to bleep this out on you mother
just I just I think I need to be left
alone okay I just need to just you don't
need to see this just gonna be a minute
and if you could just okay so we haven't
had the best luck so far obviously but
that just means that the lucky winner
gets a zero for the first time four-star
hotel flights where no keys everyone
it's good Harrington okay Jon Snow
hey I've been having a terrible time
thank god you're here actually Emily
they told me to tell you - where - shout
them to shut it down wrap it up
seriously yeah but right now okay sorry
yes wheelchair walk - I'll turn the
cameras off we'll turn it get boring you
don't want ya gone six pack whatever
let's go
so it's looking like if you really want
to see this good stuff then you're gonna
have to enter to win
you just got to click on the link below
or go to amaze calm for - Game of
Thrones easy every donation supports the
RCN foundation and their mission to
represent nurses promote excellence in
practice and shape health policies so
join me in supporting nurses by donating
right now because I may not have been
able to show you much but that won't
stop you from seeing a hell of a lot if
you get to be that lucky winner huge
dramatic exit music
I'm gonna drive off into the sunset with
my punch
is there any petrol just
I'll fix it everybody it's Charlie the
Game of Thrones people have finally
started posting mostly in meme form but
they're at the paint Hall so I'll try to
explain what's going on behind this set
because they are actually doing some
stuff they do show you a couple of
things during this funny video
thankfully this is just the beginning of
their EP kay drops we head into the
summer closer to comic-con we'll see
more legit footage we'll find out what
their social media plan is going to be
hopefully it does not include watching a
block of ice melt for a couple hours to
find out when the premiere dates
actually gonna be but the actual studio
that she's driving around in is the
paint hall that's where they do most of
their King's Landing said you may have
seen people posting about a giant red
door that they're building they used to
have a green screen here that's just
meant to be the doors of the red keep
meaning they're gonna be filming some
big CG action scene remember big final
battle they've also been constructing
bigger portions of the wall because
they're filming a lot of siege going on
I just did a video about them filming
the longest battle in the history of the
TV show like you talked about the really
big episodes hardhome battle of the
bastards they just got done with a
55-day film shoot for a single battle
that did not take place at King's
Landing so they still have a whole bunch
of stuff left to film here whether or
not you believe that it's going to be
the night king having turned a lot of
people at King's Landing with Cersei
teaming up with the forces of the worth
or if you just believe that it's going
to be Cersei vs the remaining forces of
the north and the night king will
already be gone if you're wondering why
she's still wearing this outfit from the
end of season 7 when they went beyond
the wall it's because she's headed to
Winterfell with Jon Snow it's really
cold there it's only gotten colder since
the end of last season even though I
don't think there's gonna be a
significant time jump just enough time
for the night Kings army to hit the last
hearth I think we'll get a teaser for
that in the first episode just as they
snake their way down to Winterfell the
rest of this is just meant to be funny
probably the funniest part is all the
Khal Drogo pictures in her trailer they
could probably get Jason Momoa if he
wasn't finishing Aquaman right now he
goes back to visit the set every once in
a while but then you have kid Harrington
walking to frame the look on his face
that actually looks pretty authentic you
can tell he just does not like to do
stuff like this which is why they have
emilia clarke doing this video instead
of him
because of the - he's a little more
popular of a character but the stars at
this point are powerful enough that they
could just say no I don't want to do
that
so until HBO officially puts them on the
clock like all the West world people are
on the clock right now promoting
Westworld season - you're not gonna see
kid Harrington spending a lot of time in
front of cameras talking to people but
if you are really bummed out that
there's no new episodes this year they
will be dropping new footage so there'll
be new Game of Thrones and we have the
new book coming from George our Martin
fire and blood so that'll be later this
year they've already confirmed it's
gonna be October November for most
people around the world and I don't know
exactly the kind of videos that I'm
gonna be doing for that because most of
the videos I do are for the TV show with
a little bit of book stuff so no worries
we'll figure it out when we get a little
bit closer but I will be doing DVD and
book giveaways for the rest of the year
just like I normally would so leave all
your Game of Thrones video requests in
the comments below we're just a big
reminder that Westworld season 2 is
starting this Sunday I'll be doing
episode videos just like I normally
would so if you haven't spent a lot of
time watching Westworld videos YouTube
might just hide those from you so be
sure to check out the trailer video that
I posted there so YouTube knows that you
actually do want to check out Westworld
season 2 stub and those videos will post
Sunday nights just like I would normally
do Game of Thrones it's been a hot
minute since Westworld season 1 so some
of you may have only found me after
season 1 ended so if he didn't know I do
Westworld videos there's a new round of
that Game of Thrones DVD giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll name a winner when I post new Game
of Thrones if you guys do want I will do
a Westworld giveaway when I start
posting videos this Sunday so episode 1
video posting on Sunday
brand new Westworld coming really soon
so hopefully they start dropping some
Game of Thrones season 8 promos while
that's airing so you click down here for
brand new Game of Thrones and click here
for that West world trailer again thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you